in a draft class that had plenty of
great receivers we got the best one with
us today 1400 receiving yards a vikings
record for rookies surpassing the record
set 1998 by randy moss he's justin
jefferson justin welcome to the program
how are you buddy
i'm good how are you
oh we're doing great uh not as great as
you though when when was the moment that
you just knew
i i've got this at the nfl level that
i'm just i'm going to be able to do
whatever i want to do
um i mean at first that first start uh
week three
against
um tennessee uh kind of gave me that
confidence you know going out and
getting 175 yards and
you know getting a big touchdown like i
did uh you know that boosted my
confidence a little bit that gave me
that spark that i needed uh to keep
going uh and you know that can really
tell me that i can play in this league
so uh after that game that really
boosted my confidence and uh showed that
i can play on his level
in hindsight because because we've been
trying to figure this out as great as
you were from week three on
what were they thinking week one and
week two why didn't you why didn't they
let you out of the gates week one the
way they did with randy moss in 1998
um
i feel like a little bit
of it has to do with uh you know just
being
on uh kovit and us not being able to uh
you know be with the team for a long
period of time
um you know i kind of i kind of had to
settle in a little bit you know i didn't
really
get the plays that fast because you know
we that was our first time really
walking through it when we got together
so
uh it was a little difficult to
understand the plays of resume
but i guess that the week three that's
when coach cool thought it was time for
me to to showcase my talent to the world
and um you know he gave me the
opportunity to start it i took the most
of the opportunity
uh i just want you to know first off i
mean we're big fans of yours and this
this guy that's you know above me
oh my gosh i mean love affair he loves
the vikings he loves you
i mean it's just constant blah blah blah
blah blah but it was awesome and you
know you you talk about the adjustments
of the nfl that's where i'd like to
start man like just like one or two
things about what was easier than maybe
you expected in the nfl what was harder
than maybe you expected uh in the nfl
well one uh you know just from being
from uh lsu uh you know we kind of go
against them top tier guys
uh week in and week out so um you know
coming to the league
um i knew that i'm pretty much gonna be
facing a good corner every single week
so really just bringing that lsu my uh
mortality and uh really just trying to
go in every week and uh just trying to
expose my my opponent uh but
the hardest thing of the league what
i'll have to say is just uh it being a
long season uh you know 17 weeks plus
playoffs uh as
it takes a toll on your body uh it's not
easy to go through
uh that type of season uh so you know
guys like adam and dalvin and uh guys
like that just telling me different ways
to maintain my body making sure that i'm
i'm treating my body well uh to to last
this long season yeah that's interesting
we we gloss over that a lot these days
like what like
tell me if you can give some specifics
there like what did what is the routine
that you had to finally kind of get into
to get used to like whoa i got to get
fresh here in week 14 and i'm kind of
dead what was the changes that you made
to your your approach
um i mean i'm not a guy that really gets
hurt often so um i don't i didn't really
you know
i wasn't really in the training room uh
my college career
uh but you know they had to tell me uh
you know i'm young right now but you
know a couple years down the line you
know
you want to feel a little bit so uh you
know them just telling me that i need to
be in the uh the treatment the treatment
room pretty much every day um you know
just doing something to my body uh for
it to get better um if it's just being
in the pools the hot and cold pools or
um you know just getting normal techs um
you know just different different little
stuff to um you know make my body a
little bit better each day did you find
yourself lifting more weights or less
weights than maybe you would have in
college because i know that can go
either way like some players you know oh
they lift a little more in the nfl
because it gives them a little something
other guys go i don't want to do that
because i feel like it's breaking me
down what was your your take there
um
i mean we don't really lift that much uh
but so there's that um i mean i feel
like um it's gonna really
i think the injury is gonna go down a
little bit more uh just because we're
not doing so much intense weight okay uh
like we did in college um you know we
get to really focus on uh other little
things instead of uh you know doing
heavy weight and you know maxing out and
stuff like that so
um you know we get to focus on little
things that we need in order to maintain
our body for a long period of time
you know justin watching the games on tv
it took us a long time to get used to
seeing the shots of the empty stands as
a player coming from a school that had
such a great home field advantage going
to an nfl team that has a great home
field advantage although you haven't
gotten a chance to experience that yet
how weird was it how much of an
adjustment was it for you to go out
there and perform at home with nobody
there
uh it was hard um
you know to to go from lsu uh uh a
hundred thousand plus fans to zero um is
definitely different uh we had to get
used to that and um we had to find our
own energy find our own swagger to bring
to the game because it definitely felt
like a scrimmage uh of practice at that
uh you know for the game so
i feel like that was one of the reasons
why we went one and five at the
beginning of the season you know we
didn't we didn't find that energy uh we
didn't find that swagger that we needed
to to start the season off and um you
know that second and second half of the
season we found that energy and we
kicked it up a little bit
how did you actually find it though who
was responsible for getting everything
going because it was a great turnaround
really after the bye week
um i mean all of us to be honest um you
know we knew our defense was slacking a
little bit but uh as the offense uh we
were pretty real pretty dominant we had
some some good players uh on the offense
some good leaders on offense so uh as an
offense um you know we just trying to to
get the whole team up you know making
sure the defense is staying uh you know
on their feet on their toes uh make sure
they're keeping their energy up no
matter what's going on throughout the
game uh you know everybody is just
trying to give a little boost of
excitement uh and
it was definitely difficult with no fans
uh in the building but
we had to find that spark we had to find
a way to win
i mean
you played the bucks in the regular
season okay so i want a breakdown all
right i wanna i want to know something
give me something i could talk about for
the super bowl matchup okay i mean
really what jumped out to you about
their defense and were you surprised you
know they beat the green bay packers
how'd you feel about that
what defense are you talking about the
bucks the tampa bay buccaneers yeah yeah
um
they're a great defense man um you know
overall they have great linebackers they
have a great d-line
um i mean they they have some phenomenal
players on there and uh my guy devin
white on there uh
he's been killing it too so i'm excited
to see uh you know both teams kansas
city and the bucks go at it because you
know lsu is all over the field
all over the field and like
anybody who's the baddest dude on that
bucks defense i mean right now it looks
like it's your lsu guy devin white but
anybody else that you know made you
think twice about coming over the middle
uh nah devon white that's that's the guy
right there he runs sideline the
sideline runs a 4-4 uh being that big
and uh i mean he can play um you know he
has that that fight in him he has that
that fire in him that that uh keeps him
motivated to keep going out there
playing at a high level so uh he's he's
been that guy this year did you think
they'd beat the packers
did you think they would beat the
packers you know going into that nfc
championship matchup or did you think
the packers had the advantage
i thought the packers were going to win
to be honest um you know just from them
uh being an unstoppable offense and
having a tremendous defense that they
have
i thought i thought you know they was
going to come in with that that mindset
and then that that uh fire to to keep
going at the bucks but um you know
watching the game
uh you know green bay had plenty of
opportunities to to take the uh to take
the lead right you know they the offense
wasn't really really going uh you know
quite so uh the defense did pretty good
by what getting three interceptions or
something like that so
um the defense was there but the offense
couldn't connect and get in the end zone
hey justin speaking at lsu they put out
a mock cover of uh i guess what's the
what's going to be the upcoming college
football video game with you on it there
it is the rookie of the year edition of
ea sports ncaa football tell us why you
should be the rookie of the year
um
well just looking at my stats uh you
know not not a lot of people first year
can get 1400 yards
and get over 88 receptions so uh just
that all off itself that's difficult to
do um then on top of that uh with me
having
this covet stuff not not being able to
to be with the team uh you know study
plays uh virtually all of that stuff
definitely plays a part and then on top
of that not being able to start until
week three so
um you know imagine me starting week one
and being able to play both of those
games at the beginning of the season so
who knows how many yards or touchdowns i
would have
did you hear from randy moss when you
broke his record and if he acted happy
about it do you believe he was really
happy about it
um i think he was happy about it uh just
because just the comment that he said
you know records are meant to be broken
so um you know after he said that
comment i i definitely knew that he was
he was on my side and he was definitely
rooting for me to get that
record are you going to say that when
somebody breaks your record
not at all i don't like you
that's my kind of guy right there hey i
know you got to talk about eminem's and
do all that that's why i love you man
but i do want to know this because
i mean you got great perspective rookie
year who who's the best player you saw
in football i know you saw a lot of them
but who was the one guy that you just
come away from the year going damn i
didn't realize he was
that oh man that's a lot of guys yeah i
know um
um well one for me was a big shocker it
was i mean it wasn't really a shocker
but you know travis kelsey you know him
just being at the top of the list on
receivers not even tight ends right that
was that was crazy for me uh for him to
have that many numbers
um and then for him to have that many
numbers with uh tyrek hill on the team
so
uh that was that was amazing for me to
see that um and i think stefan diggs did
tremendous for him uh to to be traded
from a team and then go to a whole new
team and have even more numbers than he
put up uh that's that was special to see
also
um and that's i mean a lot of guys have
been doing great this season it's too
hard to to name all that all right i'll
let you off the hook for now okay fine
justin we usually do these in person
super bowl week and this is one that i
wish we were doing in person for a
couple of reasons one of which is you're
here today on behalf of m ms which means
you'd have a bunch of m ms with you that
we could take from you tell us what you
got going on with m ms
uh yes m m's uh definitely excited to
connect with m ms man i've been
i've been dreaming of having this
connection with them for a long period
of time you know being being uh
a football fan
uh you know watching the super bowls on
tv you see all of these commercials and
uh different guys working with eminem so
uh eminem has definitely uh have been
working great with me um just trying to
connect uh with the world and uh we're
trying to put eminem on a bigger site
well i think we need a special edition
but what they need a purple a purple and
yellow one j and j
yellow for sure
j
not eminem all right hey great talking
to you congratulations on all your
success keep it up we look forward to
talking to you again soon thank you
appreciate it see you buddy be good good
luck
thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports